[Music]
happy birthday mr. adult man Omaha flaca
gross what was dad like his beard was
Scratchy
he had a goofy laugh I wish I'd bet him
I have something for you
from your dad it's a wizard staff I
wrote this spell so I can see for myself
who my boys grew up to be
this spell brings him back back away
back to life he wanted to beat you more
than anything
Bowie - to say - I don't know what you
started
dad don't apart dad you are in your
house we've only got 24 hours to bring
back the rest of dad we're going on a
quest all quests start with the
manticore the fearless adventurer you
mean
Corey she's over there that's the
manticore get in the vehicle I'm
escorting yo I'm giving you to the count
of three okay wait what are you doing I
don't know I'm looking for my sons
oh they went on a quest but don't worry
I told him about the map I told him
about the gym I told him about the curse
your boys are in great danger
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you boys doing a crazy Oh No dead
dead reject not great
I can't do it we're not gonna see you
dad you can do this
I'm cleaning you
my gut knows where to go don't you boy
yes you do on my way boys just stay out
of trouble
[Music]
you
[Music]
you